It's like I have,
I have northern European bullshit genes.
These mother fuckers from Kenya, you
know, it was a whole that this for sure.
It's really interesting that
the cradle of civilization,
which is where all human
beings emanated from,
Africa has the best jeans,
they have the best athletic genes. When
it comes to like physical performance,
there's no denying
they'd be off the coast.
I mean like Nigeria and that area that,
those,
that's a of Senegal,
Senegal bring up that,
that what's that wrestling they call a,
I know what you're talking about.
Frank Grillo and on fight world did
a, he went to Senegal. He goes, dude,
six foot six. I mean
they all look like, uh,
like that's what the NFL is made up of
that and that guy wrote the sports gene,
Richard Bernstein,
I think sports illustrated writer said
the fastest people in the world come from
that part of the world to be off
for coast. That's where Jamaica,
that's where the slave trade
had gone. And, and they, they,
they came from that area.
So you can actually isolate the genes.
Well one of the lambda, oh
wow. This is interesting.
They're like pawn at each
other and they're all giant.
Why did it, why the fuck?
Huh? Because they punched in. They
wrestle and they do great high level.
Greco shit watches this punching too.
Now you'll see,
watch this high level Greco Shit.
They throw Singhalese
Wrestling indycar championship.
Beautiful La Luta is the um,
the title of the video. Yep. L A space l.
U. T. T. E, single ease
wrestling, indycar championship.
Now they're working for a position but,
and if you see some of these guys,
you see what their bodies look like.
It's so just so ridiculous. Like,
like they, they live on fish and rice.
I mean, frank went there, it's so poor.
And he said, you just see
dudes where you're like, well,
if I had a body like that,
I would never work clothes. So I don't
understand what they're doing here.
They're just getting coaching, just
getting positioned. Whoever gets thrown.
These guys are rock stars in Senegal.
Okay. Do you need coaching? No, no, no.
You'll see now they punched me.
Tell you something.
Cain Velasquez shoots a power double in
these motherfuckers here on the back and
the stand. Sir, I'm going to ask you
to know that's true. Five minutes.
Five minutes dead.
Five minutes.
There's still a lot because they're
waiting to get passionate cakes, bro.
It's like sumo dude nuts. Oh,
exactly. It's nonsense. No, excuse me.
Tread trip. Oh, they're
punching each head. Dude know
shit. Dude. This is serious.
Oh Shit. They're punching from the clinch.
Yeah, Bro. Why is this is fighting. Yes.
Adjust his headband. Yeah. You got to
always adjust your headband time. Tom.
What does time? What did they do in time?
Time. That's it. That's done much. No,
I may be not. I'm confused. Hold. Keep
going with it's gotta be a better one.
You got to see the heavyweights.
They heavy weights are the championship.
I figured maybe it just sucks and you're
really into it. Besides foreign, sir.
That's possible. I'm telling you.
I've seen some incredible lamb.
Those dudes are play a petty case. You
will respect lamb book yet. Let's see.
Another one. Kickboxing world
champion. Oh, go to the far
right one. That one. Okay,
here we go. Now we'll see what's up.
Kickboxing world champion challenges,
singling these wrestlers.
Who is this kickboxing world champions
like a documentary? I sir, I don't care.
I want to see how it's not like
I've got to find the fight. Oh,
is it like an hour ago? There's still
shit. All sorts of stuff going on here.
Who is this? A kickboxing were old
and he's like, there's Sufi Muslim,
so they're hanging out with them
very, very spiritually. Kickbox. Okay.
Uh,
orally say his name.
Brian or learning or lean Duarte orally.
Duarte, French, multiple kickboxing,
Muay Thai and Choto con karate champion.
Sounds like me.
So it looks like he's
learning from these folks.
I don't think he's really challenging
them. Okay, let's see what happens in the,
there we go. Look at, look at my man
right there. Set up saying still,
what does it say instead of
saying, still, just let it go.
We'll see what happens here. Are they
wrestling? Yeah. Oh, so they're wrestling,
but what? It's all Bouma c that dude
back up a little. Almost see that.
Do the kickboxing guy interact with them?
There we go.
Okay.
Okay. Let's see. Throws. Okay.
They're just teaching him to throw. Oh,
they're teaching them some technique.
It's kind of cool that they do it
on the beach though. That's smart.
That's a duck under right there. It
took his back. Yeah. Sandra Nelson,
they know some wrestling
techniques. Wrestling is, you know,
you could make the
argument that wrestling,
would you say that wrestling is probably
the best thing you could ever do coming
up? If you want to get an MMA,
like they have the space. Yes.
I think wrestling's the
most important sport. Yeah.